well there's always been gangs and music
we just don't we just see it now because
our music is the number one job do you
think back in the day like frank sinatra
had like my fiance i was just gonna say
that yeah
yeah we didn't have mafia tires yeah
mafia orders right
right this is what it is because anybody
who's trying to make money the easiest
way to get in it is in this music
like if you got money you want to put it
somewhere like we don't have no other
outlets that's what this documentary
talks about
hip-hop uncover talks about when
we were hustling and then we eventually
took that money to get into something
and try to do something positive
you know you might have a cousin or
hunty i'm a cousin a uncle a friend
who wants to do music okay what we need
studio time i got you
yeah you know and then it starts going
past that you start seeing the little
jays you start seeing the helios start
seeing the dudes making
making it and that's what hip-hop untold
is it talks about
us and our struggles in music you don't
hear about us
it's not it's not geared towards
the artist it's geared towards the
people behind the artist like when i met
you
like for instance if i had a new artist
right now like with osbs my group osbs
criticality
i introduced them and told them i called
you to do an interview with them yeah
i heard you was coming here that's hip
hop uncovered that's what
that's why they call us the power
brokers because we already had a
relationship
when you first met nipsey nipsey met you
through steve
09 and me he didn't have that
relationship with you right he couldn't
have called you
and and what people don't understand is
you need those power brokers
to help introduce you to people and then
those power brokers have to have a trust
in a relationship that comes from
somebody else